bonsoir et même que votre étude et les
mots sont importants sous forme d'appel
à la prudence au gouvernement qu'est-ce
que vous dites exactement ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que entre le moment où les
engagements électoraux ont été pris et
aujourd'hui la situation économique a
changé de manière considérable alors que
l'ennemi à abattre était l'inflation cet
été maintenant on voit peindre à
l'horizon ralentissement économique à
court terme et une croissance assez
modérée au cours des années qui suivent
en même temps on est en train de nager
en pleine incertitude et un contexte
mondial où il y a beaucoup de tensions
on n'est pas encore sûr de l'effet de la
hausse des taux d'intérêt sur les
ménages sur leur consommation sur leur
confiance et donc tout ce contexte là il
l'appelle à la prudence et donc un appel
à la prudence ça passe par une révision
des priorités budgétaires allez-vous
même jusqu'à dire qu'on ne devrait pas
baisser les impôts comme le gouvernement
de l'envisage alors c'est normal
lorsqu'on fait face à une situation
comme celle-ci inflation ralentissement
de vouloir aider les ménages qui ont qui
en ont le plus besoin ce qu'on dit c'est
que il y a des mesures qui sont
ponctuelles l'échec 3,5 milliards de
dollars qu'on met dans l'économie mais
ces ponctuel par contre il y a des
mesures qui sont plus structurelles et
là s'il y a certains ça suscite quelques
questions la baisse d'impôt c'est une
mesure qui est structurelle on va venir
se priver année après année de 5
milliards de dollars par année alors
même que
le rythme de croissance de nos dépenses
notamment en santé va une nuit et va
augmenter de manière rapide au cours des
prochaines années et en plus on vient
donc on vient réduire les versements au
fond des générations pour financer cette
baisse d'impôts et ça ça contrevient en
partie à l'esprit de la loi l'esprit
d'équité intergénérationnel de la loi
sur la font les Fonds
des générations le remettre en question
vous semblez penser qu'il faut protéger
le fond des générations pourquoi tout à
fait mais c'est normal que des questions
d'endettement conséquées les montants
qui sont accumulés dans le fond sont
importants donc c'est normal qu'on se
pose des questions par contre il faut
absolument préserver le mécanisme qui
fait que on laisse de côté un certain
montant d'argent qu'on préserve des
choix que les gouvernements doivent
faire au jour le jour pour faire face à
différents défis la santé l'éducation
les changements climatiques mais on
préserve ce montant là pour ne pas
refiler la facture aux générations
futures quel est le danger en ce moment
qu'est-ce qui nous guette alors que
l'économie ralentit qu'on veut baisser
de façon structurelle des revenus en
baissant les impôts qu'on pigeants de
fond des générations qu'est-ce qui est
important ou dangereux ou risquer selon
vous
ce qu'il faut faire c'est vraiment
s'assurer que de ne pas créer un
précédent un précédent où on va piger de
manière arbitraire dans des économies
qu'on a fait pour les générations
futures et nous ce qu'on dit c'est que
il y a moyen encore aujourd'hui
d'honorer les promesses électorales mais
de préserver les principes du fond des
générations et pour ça il faut peut-être
penser à moderniser les règlements
autour du fond des générations par
exemple en mars 2023 le gouvernement va
annoncer des nouvelles cibles
d'endettement nous on dit à ce moment-là
est-ce qu'on peut présenter un plan de
réduction de la dette à long terme et
mettre en place des nouvelles règles qui
régleraient un petit peu comment est-ce
qu'on peut réduire les versements au
fond les allouer à d'autres fins mais
que ce soit fait avec des paramètres
clairs et transparents
sur l'équilibre budgétaire qui quand ça
va mal et saute exactement comme en 2008
comme pendant la crise financière en
2008 en 2021 on a suspendu la loi sur
l'équilibre budgétaire c'est noté normal
il y avait des dépenses importantes
qu'il fallait faire pour faire face à la
pandémie aujourd'hui on fait face à un
ralentissement économique donc moins de
revenus de l'État potentiellement et
dans ce contexte là il faut se poser la
question est-ce qu'il y a moyen de
préserver cette discipline budgétaire
qui veut que on met de l'argent de côté
lorsque ça va bien puis on peut en
dépenser plus quand ça va moins bien
mais en même temps ne pas être
tributaire d'une décision politique de
on suspend la loi où on la remet est-ce
que l'inquiétude c'est de revenir à des
déficits et à des déficits structurels
on a quand même l'impression qu'on est
presque revenu à l'équilibre sinon même
en surplus budgétaire est-ce qu'il y a
pas une possibilité avec le
vieillissement de la population qu'on
revienne en déficit structurel mais ce
qu'il y a un risque de croissance des
revenus qui va qui va être plus lente
que ce qu'on a connu dans les années
avant la pandémie on avait une bonne
croissance économique les revenus de
l'État sont été au rendez-vous
aujourd'hui à part le ralentissement
qu'on va vers en 2023 l'après les
prévisions de croissance même en 2024 25
26 elles sont quand même gestes elles
sont plus faibles que ce qu'on avait
avant donc mais en même temps population
qui vieillit des besoins en santé qui
sont énormes des changements climatiques
à combattre et donc les besoins sont de
plus en plus importants comment
s'assurer de faire ça ben il faut qu'on
ait des finances publiques qui soient
soutenables pour y faire ça on verra si
l'appel à la prudence que vous lancez
sera entendu dans la mise à jour
économique de la semaine prochaine puis
surtout dans le budget probablement
possiblement au mois de mars merci
d'avoir été avec nous merci pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]